le concours d'entrée à sciences po c'est
peut-être bientôt la fin alors après la
suppression annoncée de l'ena sur ce
qu'on a décidé de réformer sa scolarité
pas qu'un peu donc en supprimant le
concours d'entrée c'est ce que nous dit
d'ailleurs son directeur frédéric union
qui donne une interview au figaro que
vous pourrez lire sur le site très
bientôt et demain dans le journal
ses arguments il les développe mais nous
on en parle dès maintenant vous êtes
comme ça arthur berda à brûle pourpoint
qu'est ce que ça vous dit cette
suppression du concours d'entrée à
sciences po qu'est ce que c'est je pense
qu'il faut faire attention au message
qui est envoyé avec lena avec sciences
po et c'est ce dont il faut se méfier
c'est de ne pas envoyer le message que
finalement sciences po ben c'est pour
tout un chacun
d'ailleurs vous avez quelqu'un fasse
avoue qu'il n'a pas fait sciences po et
donc il faut il faut se méfier du
message qui est envoyé en revanche si
l'objet c'est de permettre de s'inscrire
dans ce que plaidez l'exécutif c'est
tout à fait logique c'est richard
descoings qui a initié ce mouvement à
l'époque où il avait déjà supprimé le
concours écrits et laisser un concert
choral il avait permis à des étudiants
issus de zep soit intégrée à sciences po
via une voie parallèle donc c'est la
logique politique derrière derrière
derrière cette démarche là on la voit
assez facilement en revanche faut se
méfier que dans les faits sciences po ça
reste quand même une des grandes écoles
françaises
jean louis boré choisir je vous donne un
argument qui pourrait être celui
d'alexis parce que je crois connaître
ses dires finalement on en arrive à des
solutions un peu bancal parce que
l'éducation nationale ne fait pas son
travail et j'en sais rien moi je suis
assez à l'aise parce que j'ai fait
sciences po mais je suis rentré en
seconde et direct je ne suis pas connais
pas beaucoup qui avait fait une licence
une licence et une maîtrise avant de
l'être et donc je suis arrivé comme ça
donc je suis d'une neutralité absolue
diplômé de sciences po mais pas passés
par le concours en revanche moi je vais
beaucoup de mal à répondre à votre
question parce que le problème c'est
celui du mode de ces deux sélections le
mois où le mot et sélection est horrible
mais quand même il ya des gens qui ne
sont pas assurances peau qui à un moment
il ya des gens qui sont à sciences po
donc le problème c'est de savoir comme
on les recrute alors moi je
je les attends je vais lire avec
beaucoup de beaucoup d'intérêt la
l'interview du directeur de sciences po
mais pour l'instant je n'ai pas
connaissance de ça et je voudrais savoir
quelle est la part du livret scolaire
quelle est la part de l'entretien quelle
est la part des points de vue politiques
quelle est la part de la culture de tout
ça et là aussi c'est dans les travaux
pratiques toussaint ce manifeste
simplement aujourd'hui on compte est de
plus en plus le concours comme mode de
sélection
je crois qu'on a raison de relativiser
mais qu' il faut quand même le remplacer
par quelque chose qui tienne la route
sur des normes et surtout quelque chose
de plus juste ou de moins injuste
c'est ça la question c'est parce que
jean louis borloo absolument raison tout
le monde on n'entrera pas à la fin des
fins donc comment on prend ce qui rend
dire jusqu'à présent il y avait un truc
tout bête isabelle le concours ceux qui
avaient les meilleures notes étaient
reçus et les autres bases étaient pas
pris bon bah c'était comme ça et par
quoi on le remplace alors là on comprend
pas ça va être bon les notes de la
scolarité avec le biais inévitable que
selon les établissements scolaires dans
lequel on est on n'a pas le même niveau
de notes c'est que le concours de tout
le monde
rob réunis parce que moi j'ai passé le
bourget fait j'ai passé un concours mais
c'est çui là en plus on me le retirer
mais tout le monde tout le monde retire
et tout le monde allait faire acquitter
j'étais 3e
il ne restera plus rien donc tout le
tout le monde réunis dans la même grande
salle à cachan et c'est dans les mêmes
conditions les mêmes questions le même
temps pour répondre
il ya comme une égalité alors on peut
dire que derrière des inégalités
culturelles héritées de l'essence d'être
tout ce qu'on veut mais n'empêche que
tout le monde fait son concours dans les
mêmes conditions et c'est égal là on
nous dit ça va être selon les notes dans
les établissements scolaires et tout le
monde sait très bien que j'aie
s'allumant scolaires ont pas les mêmes
qu'à force et que de que les dde qu'on
peut avoir 12 dans des très très
excellence établissements scolaires
parisiens du centre de paris est là et
qu'ils valent
qui équivalent à 1 18 ailleurs ton plus
cher la nièvre et mais bon à la limite
on veut dire bah c'est un moyen de
rétablir une mixité sociale bon et la
turbie pleurait savent être un mix avec
notamment l'entretien mais de cet
entretien il faut pas poser de questions
de culture générale dans lequel joue pas
voter parce que c'est injuste mais
l'entretien est ce quelque chose de plus
injuste que l'entretien l'entretien dans
lequel on pose pas de questions de
connaissances s'appelle une note de
gueule c'est au moment où on dit il faut
pas rétablir la ségrégation sociale
le copinage les réseaux td rats ça donne
la possibilité à la direction d'orienter
celui will win non en fonction du plein
de cryptage agrégation culturel culturel
c'est quand même moi ça me paraît quand
même assez rivière qu'il reste deux
temps alors puisque nous tout le monde a
mis son cv sur la tam c'était la même
trajectoire que jean louis bourlanges
licence de lettres puis anicien deuxième
année il y avait mis un petit quelque
chose quand même
mais en fait la question fondamentale
qui devrait être la même d'ailleurs pour
toute admission dans le supérieur c'est
quel est le critère qui permet de faire
en sorte que dans une filière haye les
gens qui vont y réussir qu'elles soient
faites pour eux qu'elle puisse sans
doute le concours à l'heure actuelle
avait un caractère très sélectif
d'ailleurs je pourrais ajouter à cette
partie très autobiographique je pense
que j'aurais pas eu le concours s'il
était il ya 30 ans qu'il est aujourd'hui
mais là derrière cela je sais pas quel
est le message qu on va envoyer on est
on est aussi dans un contexte un peu
particulier dans un rapport qui très
dégradée à l'égard des élites alors
c'est complètement tarte à la crème en
là mais du coup on en oublie un peu que
bah ce pays à un moment admirer ces
élites trouvé que c'était bien qu'il ya
des gens qui passent des concours que ça
les distingue dans des trajectoires
d'ascension d'ascension sociale
tout ça doit être mise en perspective
par rapport à ça les concours sont plus
acceptables dans leurs aspects
méritocratique quand on a l'impression
que la méritocratie fonctionnaires les
prévenus sont juste à vous c'est qu on
est en pleine exploitation du président
pompidou qui est exactement le contraire
de la négation du concours pompidou
c'est exactement le modèle quand vous
dites c'est un normalien agrégé de
lettres un homme qui a vraiment une
culture une capacité professionnelle
d'enseignants et qui est et qui a été
remarquable premier ministre et un
président de la république tout à fait
honorable jusqu'au moment où
malade il a empêché d'exercer pleinement
ses activités et concours mais chaud il
est l'exemple même du modèle ancien qu
on abolit elle encore le célèbre que les
concours ne prennent même plus la mixité
sociale on en déduit qu'il faut
supprimer les concours le problème c'est
qu'il faut que précédemment cités
sociales dans les concours et donc faire
en sorte que l'éducation nationale
permettent à des enfants de catégories
modestes et populaire d'intégrer les
bonnes filières et les bonnes séquences
mais ouais mais c'est ça la vérité s'est
passé c'est comme de la
là encore c'est se cacher les choses que
de que deux on casse le thermomètre
parce que la température est pas la
bonne c'est absurde pour compléter ce
que vous disiez jean georges pompidou
fils d'instituteur on dit souvent qu
aujourd'hui les enfants d'enseignants
qui réussissent le mieux
encore aujourd'hui je mets je n'ouvre
pas de débat approuvez-vous la
suppression du concours d'entrée à
sciences po oui à 34 pour soi donc une
majorité de non le pacte nous dit si
l'on supprime le concours alors il faut
supprimer le concours d'entrée en
médecine c'est dur en passe de l'être
non dans les écoles d'ingénieurs et de
commerce pour nicolas l'entrée sans
concours c'est la porte ouverte à toutes
les magouilles et snap approuverait la
suppression de sciences po les étudiants
doivent apprendre à penser mais encore
une fois ce débat risque on apprend plus
à penser